was bisher geschah alina und sören sind
seit einem jahr verlobt sie wollen drei
monaten heiraten
du hast alle chancen der welt und dann
nimmst du dir ein mädel die ich weiß
nicht
die von von einer straße kommt die
oberschicht hat natürlich das war immer
einen vergoldeten königstochter dass ich
überlegt habe ich habe nur 13.000
[Gelächter]
richtiges dorf so kleines morgen wird es
dann aus diesen drei anbringen und damit
viel spaß beim zweiten teil von ein
stinktier lebt über seine verhältnisse
es gibt nur eine einblendung sie zu
beschreiben
kleine rover mit geld von anderen flex
also angibt und dazu noch eine doppelte
stieg die brücke muss muss loswurde
wer kennt nicht die will ihre bitte komm
können sie noch 5000 euro von
unternehmen bitte komm ich möchte ihn
wirklich noch mehr geld in ihrem laden
dann lassen sie würden auch mehr
verdienen nicht überlegt
hamburg hamm bockum zu bringen aber
musste zwei tage später
syrien hat die ringe bezahlt und
abgeholt das budget ist längst
überschritten er ist pleite durch alina
ski ist grenzenlos wie hat er das
gemacht was drin kostet 1000 brillant
5000 sache zweimal 1000 mal 1000 und
7000 10.000 7017 1000 adressen btv zu
direkten 4000 ja auch noch chinesischen
auktion versteigert 13.000 euro zur
verfügung gehabt 10.000 euro habe ich
gegeben
12.000 euro an die ringe nein ich habe
irgendwann schluss dir ich bin jetzt mit
minus 3.000 euro ich bin pleite
das klima zwischen den nächsten monat
hast du wieder gelb kam ich mach den
vorschlag gegeben die kutsche angucken
will ich nicht brauchen wir nicht und
zeit habe ich auch nicht jetzt reicht
das war eine konsequente und auch
hasserfüllte andere nein ich will nicht
von ich habe auch keine zeit ich muss
sagen muss klicke ich eine lieferung von
bild beschlägen führen sagt das sind so
dinge und da brauche ich endlich den mut
sich dafür was kriegt ja gold beschläge
für eine lieferung von beschlägen fühlen
sag ich nur dich warum von geldbeträgen
ich habe ja mit meinen gold beschlägen
aber was man sagt es ist passiert warum
sollte ich mir sorgen und ich habe dann
kannst du gleich mal deine mutti nach
dem kredit fragen wer ist gestorben
warum ist diese person gestorben und wie
irgendwelche beschläge für den sack
bezahlen wenn du sowieso schon unterwegs
bist bei den eltern kannst du gleich mal
deine mutti nach dem kredit fragen sind
los
wieso eigentlich nicht mehr sofort alter
es nicht
der bürger warum sollte man warum die
mutter mehr party nichts zu tun die
schätze ich habe den ganzen tag nur
abend ich habe die bayerischen fit ist
und zwar habe ich für dich tausend euro
für dich in die küche und den rest
bekommen was sie gesagt haben das können
wir das tor zu holen und den rest aber
dafür kommen sie ja ich glaube die toto
diesem dieses spiel blicken also die
kirche mal leute was macht ja was ich
sagen wollte max wiebels der spaß konnte
ich gar nichts sagen weil er noch im
zimmer war
sie von der mutti ist doch egal was ist
das wieder verließ zähne
er hat ein porzellan tausend euro
kassiert
entspannend und natürlich in dem moment
wo es zum ersten mal seite steht seine
mutter hinter dieser faktoren ist völlig
pleite und wird immer mehr von seiner
zukünftigen ehefrau unter druck gesetzt
verzweifelt sieht der 25 jährige nur
noch einen ausweg er hat es auf die
12.000 euro seines vaters abgesehen die
er für die bezahlung von gold beschlägen
zu hause aufbewahrt war die ganz kurz
die golfschläge welcher sagt wäre es
nicht machen das was ist über 12.000
goldstücke für irgendeinen sagt ich habe
tatsächlich eine vermutung ich glaube
wenn man wahrscheinlich weil wir wie
berlin auf ganze unterkunft haus geben
findet man exakt diese dreht ok selbst
[Musik]
er sucht aber auch wirklich über alles
wie immer doch nicht das geld die 100
frankreich
auch stabile versteckt jeder mensch hat
durch die 12.000 euro direkt auf seine
seite in bar syrien ist von alina so
emotional abhängig dass er komplett sein
gespür verloren hat für recht und moral
ich glaube da liegt ein fehler vor werk
eine evolution aber mal kurz realistisch
die frau schon so viele hier voll
eingesehen und kommentiert hatte
wirklich gedacht dass diesmal nichts
gekauft
der diebstahl der 3000 euro und das vbs
lässt mutter patricia keine ruhe
[Musik]
ich stellte mir in der schlange auf dem
fußboden ja warum winter so eine rasse
[Musik]
wirklich einfach das kinderzimmer in
einem airbnb patricia fühlt sich in
ihrer vorahnung bestätigt alina das geld
geklaut und sie wird nicht zulassen dass
wir so eine diebin heiratet okay ganz
kurz mal das ist ein buch liebe also
unter dem buch liebe lernen roboter
schauspielerin wie sie jetzt menschen
feiern können und darunter liegen
natürlich zu versorgen mal klappt und
sie wird nicht zulassen dass wir so eine
liebe heiratet normalfall zwei stunden
später mutter patricia will nach ihrer
entdeckung syrien und alina sofort wenn
nach ihrer entdeckung syrien und aline
die 49-jährige art nicht in welcher
katastrophalen finanziellen lage sich
sören befindet wieso alle es ihr so die
weißen job da schauen wir nicht
zuschläge bezahlen müssen und stabilen
aus betreiber aus treffen sie doch auch
sie zum ersten mal in seinem leben kämen
aber in der ton ist und samsung
negativen an dass dies auch ein wechsel
dieses fahrwerk durfte ich ihn abkaufen
zum zweiten mal wie kann man ein
einmaliges 22 mal abkaufen erst einmal
bei ihm gekauft hat wie es ihm verkauft
und dann hat er das noch mal aber ist
ein einmaliges angebot ist ein
zweimaliges sei als maurer irgendjemand
hat dieses ein aus diesem hause
gestohlen hat es dann unserem juwelier
angeboten
der hat es wieder erkannt hat mich
angerufen und ich durfte ihm dieses ei
zum zweiten male abkaufen aber er wird
immerhin gekauft ok ich erkenne
eindeutig dass dieses ei gestohlen wurde
aus dem haus von einer sehr bekannten
gründen von mir hören keine erklärung
ich weiß was vergessen mal fünf minuten
dann helfe ich euch doch mal ein
bisschen auf die spur das war mal 3000
euro jetzt 1.700 kommt ist nicht einfach
so vom himmel gelungen ein junge in
welchem seegebiet ist militär werde
regina ist
ich finde das vormals anleger dann hast
du uns noch lose ich da gar nicht so hab
ich zu haben ich hoffe ihr habt das geht
natürlich eine mutter zu sein er kommen
mache ich so ein scheiß wir haben uns
geklaut aber ihr vorrecht irgendwann
lang genug alex ihr müsst ihr war nicht
auf der erde
merkst du denn nicht dass diese frau es
einzig und alleine auf dein geld
abgesehen hat ob unser geld auf unserer
gehörten geld du kannst mir sagen was
ich mit diesem blöden überraschungsei
gute habe ich habe damit nichts zu tun
und wahrscheinlich mit den 3000 euro die
gestohlen worden sind auch rund 3000
euro gestohlen
ja machen ihre 3000 ich habe damit
nichts zu tun
und wahrscheinlich mit den 3000 euro die
gestohlen worden sind auch nicht nein
kann ich aber nicht mehr dann der
heilige geist vielleicht
an dieser stelle was für eine story für
ganz kurze wir können nicht aufhören
irgendjemand ist gestorben irgendwie
noch einmal 3000 euro geklaut
wo wann hier könnt ihr euch gleich ein
für euch folgendes video anschauen und
jetzt leute die weisheit des tages für
eine die jugendleitung verzweifelt sind
heiratet können geldgeil es stimmt hier